une scène qui revient sans cesse après
une fusillade
l'installation de croix à la mémoire des
victimes
ici on cherche le réconfort un câlin de
consolation
et quelques caresses aussi que l'on
donne aux chiens pour se changer les
idées le temps d'un instant et pour ne
plus penser à l'horreur pourtant
inoubliable
et puis surtout on laisse parler ses
émotions et on ose pleurer ses morts
ce rituel réconfortant bonifie veille
depuis dix ans un peu partout aux états
unis en fait depuis la tuerie à l'école
sendyoo qu au connecticut
des croix il y en a aussi devant l'école
théâtre du carnage de mardi
pour doha mendoza grand-mère de la
petite amri gars à 10 ans tuée dans la
classe la peine est immense et
inconsolable
il y a aussi les enfants qui ont survécu
à la tuerie qu'il faudrait conforter le
pasteur michael johnson y participent en
apportant des peluches des petits
cadeaux mais surtout en donnant du temps
pour les écouter et comprendre et les
aider à vivre avec ces terribles moments
indélébile ainsi semblant d'âme
m
alors quelles solutions pour éviter une
autre tragédie a
weak hama
et le contrôle des armes à feu dans tout
ça
morales ancien élève de l'école se fait
le porte-voix d'une certaine partie de
la population américaine qui pensent que
la sécurité dans les écoles fait défaut
les armes à feu ici c'est une vache
sacrée qu'il ne faut pas toucher 2 dont
purepeople au
psg une façon de penser assez répandue
entre les questions sans réponse et le
douloureux deuil les texans souffrent en
silence et comme d'or à mendoza cette
souffrance fera partie de toute leur vie
ici frédéric arnould radio-canada ou
valdes et au texas